Donald Trump will face 37 criminal
counts when he appears in a court in
Miami next week he's accused of
mishandling classified documents which
he kept on leaving office obstructing
justice and making false statements if
convicted the former U.S president could
face up to 10 years in prison well
Milestone joins me now from Bedminster
New Jersey where Mr Trump is staying at
his golf club and and marks some more
information now coming through to us
about this indictment
yes new remarkable
um unprecedented information in a
indictment which has now been unsealed
unsealed in the last few minutes an
indictment that runs to nearly 50 pages
long 50 pages which the former president
and his lawyers will be looking at right
now a mile or two from here at his Golf
Club in New Jersey it was last night at
7 p.m when he received a call from his
lawyer telling him that he would be
arrested next Tuesday that he needed to
go to Miami to face a court face a judge
we are now absorbing this um indictments
um picking it apart understanding for
the first time what it is that Donald
Trump uh the 45th president of the
United States is accused of having done
and it all relates to classified
documents that he took from his from the
White House and took them down to his
Resort in Mar-A-Lago looking at the
document that I have here in front of me
we can now see see for the first time
what these classified documents
contained 0.3 of the document says the
classified documents Trump stored in his
boxes included information regarding
defense and weapons capabilities of both
the United States and foreign countries
the United States nuclear program
potential vulnerable vulnerabilities of
the United States and its allies to
military attack and plans for possible
retaliation in response to a foreign
attack now at the heart of all this is
not just the fact that he took them
illegally it is claimed out of the White
House these are classified documents but
that he stored them in a place that was
far from secure a a resort down in
Florida that any that visitors can come
and go from we also get some detail here
a little later on in the indictment
about moments here in Bedminster where
Donald Trump is said to have talked
about these documents in July 2021 at
the Trump National Golf Course here in
bed Minster during an audio recorded
meeting with a writer and two members of
Staff Trump showed and described a plan
of attack that he was prepared that was
prepared for him by the Department of
Defense and Trump told the individuals
that were presidents of the present at
the golf course the plan was highly
confidential and secret and he said as
president I should have Declassified it
now I can't you know that this is still
a secret the the the key part there is
that he is admitting in recorded uh in
in stuff that was recorded that he knew
that these were not Declassified that
contradicts what he has since said was
that he has Declassified them well he at
the time said that they were still
classified this is really remarkable
stuff about a man who is not just a
hasbi not just a former president but a
man who wants to be president once again